first how to chop an onion
This is [the] root that's absolutely crucial leave [that] on there you cut that off the onion will start to bleed and you'll start crying
Rapidly Slice go forward that weight of the knife do the work
Three fingers one in front two behind and this part of the knuckle is Gonna guide the knife
Fingers on top of the onion point the knife towards the root and [try] to get as close [to] the root as possible nice
long
stroke
And then push the onion back together push the knife Halfway in to the onion slightly tilt the knife down
one at the top
And then gripping the onion like a tennis ball holding it together in place
With the weight of the blade to cut through that onion to get to the base [of] the root
Again turn it round up and down motion
And that's what we left there. No waste just the root and look
There you've got a really nice finely chopped onion
Basmati rice the king of all Rice's light fluffy delicious, and I'm going to show you how to cook it perfectly
now start off with
400 grams of Rice
rice in
spot-on
Something to do now is just rinse off the dust and start
cold water always
And is rinse the rice that
[stops] the rice from becoming clumpy in the pan and allowed it yummy nice light and fluffy
Once it's cooked rice into the pan [now] to make a plain fluffy rice exciting. We're going to choose it
three cardamom Pods
And just get the pods and just [pierce] them so it allows all that flavor to come out
cardamom Pods, and then
Star anis now these are beautiful whole Star anis
It makes it really nice and fragrant
Salt and pepper lot easier to season the rice now
Then it is once. It's cooked
We start to break up when you season once it's cooked now basically one part rise to one and a half part water
six hundred mils always started off in cold water
cold water in
onto the gas
Lid on
bring it up to the ball as quick as possible and turn it down and let it simmer for eight to ten minutes and that's
The secret behind cooking great rice allow it to steam as it's cooking
Do not lift that lid up
Lid off
Mmm, it smells
Aromatic basically all the waters absorbed the rice has doubled in size and is nice and light and fluffy
take the star [in] [ease] out the
Cardamom Pods the all should have risen to the top
pods out
Take your fork
[fluff] it through basically just sort of starts to open thing back up
Once [you've] fought you through [becomes] really nice and light [and] fluffy and there that is perfectly cooked rice
This is basically a fileted side of salmon. It's been taken off the bone and now
skin off
Pick up your knife a really nice broad
flexible
[affinity] knife
little Sharpen lift up the base of the tail
and then just nick a little bit at the end there twist the knife almost as if it's
Horizontally underneath the salmon pull the skin and you slice
The salmon underneath and let the knife do the work now get your skin
Flip it back over and check your not leaving too much salmon on top of the skin pull it back
Nice, and slowly get the skin wrap it around your fingers
Pull the Salmon towards you and then just all the way through
Lay that down
One Nicely skinned Salmon, just like a perfect snake skin
Get your knife and just run the [knife] down
And then with a pair of tweezers these are fish tweezers, but you can use normal tweezers
look for the head up and
Pull and with [the] skin being removed from underneath the salmon the pin bones come out a lot easier
The pin Bones only go to just basically halfway
Along the [filat] one nice fill it of salmon beautiful
It's far harder working in the kitchen with a blunt knife than it is with a sharp knife the secret behind keeping a [sharp] knife
Sharpen it before and every time you use [it] first grip the steel feel really come to about holding still imagine
You're holding a tennis racket or you're playing squash [gotta] be really comfortable with it now
45 degrees confident grip confident grip with a knife
This is the butt of the steel really important to keep your fingers behind there you never grip us steel with your fingers over that
Because the knife comes back in you [just] lost a finger always grip behind
Nice long strokes, so we get the whole of the blade over
steel
Stroke and we start from the bottom to the top so [there]
across there across
Throw strokes over the top of the steel and then come back in to meet send back underneath
It is so dangerous working in the kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause so much damage
Working with a sharp knife is ten times quicker more efficient now
That's ready to start chopping
It can be easily undercooked or overcooked here's how to do it properly
First water [in] nice large pan to make sure that passes got sufficient room to cook evenly nicely seasoned absolutely crucial
Olive [oil] in that stops the pasta from sticking together
[reach] up to the Ball
That's the rolling boil the secret there. It stops the pass from sticking together, and it gently rolls it around now
This is angel passed a nice thin
Pasta takes 304 minutes so into the pan
There's a hits the water it melts and then you turn it round tongs as that starts to melt gently
Twist that into the pan bring it back up to the boil if your better timing then set a timer
Beautiful to test it lift a little strand
And you actually feel it with your fingers still nice and firm
mmm
I'll dente not a bite not a strong buy
But just really nice and firm inside definitely not crunchy and then into a colander drain the pasta
in A
light seasoned salt and pepper [a]
Tablespoon of olive oil
mix that through
That stops it [from] sticking together and look there you go beautiful pasta Al Dente
Mmm [cook] perfectly let's give me a little raise okay, and let's get cooking and shall we
That's a big one